[Music]
this is it amy moment of truth
remember might be he's the success don't
screw up
come on
i can't
watch but i can't look away
[Applause]
[Music]
when your uncle upon and i went
searching for the hamster of darkness
what the
finding you
was the best thing that ever happened to
me
i can't believe we got to be seen with
that freak chicken hair everybody laughs
at me dad would you expect he's mostly
chicken no he's mostly hair shaking here
sounds like they're cheering
need a guide i'm meg
follow in my footsteps and you'll be
okay well that's too bad looks like
we'll have to head back
follow me
[Music]
to enter the temple one must pass the
three deadly trials
why can't it ever be two trials
captain
i'm going down don't move
all of us are born with things that make
us different
who's ready to ride
[Music]
the only choice we have is recognize
that our differences are what makes us
special
here we go
oh please
you couldn't have brought the extra
large whip could you meg
how many flying hairs have you ever seen
you have wings don't you i can't lie
you can
i can't fly
[Music]
bye